- When you have that passion,
you will get back up when
you get knocked down.
All sorts of people say
all sorts of things.
Yeah, our perspective is
to keep our heads down.
I feel like the luckiest
person in the world
every day because of what I get to do.
You know, I think you have
to believe in yourself.
I think the minute that
you have a backup plan,
you've admitted that you're
not going to succeed.
My journey was one of
jumping in feet-first.
And there's nothing like
rolling your sleeves up
and failing a bunch of times to figure out
how to do it right.
I've always seen money as a tool
for being able to make a difference.
Big waves come and they go,
but you're there for a reason.
And the 'saving more lives'
piece, when you're talking
about someone that you
love, you'd do anything.
- She's an American
businesswoman and entrepreneur.
She's the CEO of a blood
test company founded in 2003.
As of January 2016, Forbes
estimated her net worth
to be $3.6 billion.
She's Elizabeth Holmes, and
here are her top 10 rules
for success.
- I would focus first on why
you're doing what you're doing,
and really, really understand
if you're building a company,
what's the reason that
you're building this company,
and what is the role
that you want to have?
And why are you there?
Because once you understand it,
and you understand your reason for it,
you'll build the company differently.
I would say to make sure what you're doing
is something that you love,
and that you are so deeply
and incredibly passionate
about that if you got fired,
you would still want to do it.
And if you weren't CEO, you
would still want to do it,
because when you have that passion,
you will get back up when
you get knocked down.
And you will get knocked
down over, and over,
and over again, and you
win by getting back up.
And our journey has been nothing but that,
in the context of falling
in love with this mission,
and feeling like the luckiest
people on the planet,
to be able to do it every single day,
and fighting for it
because we love it so much.
And I've always been a great
believer in the concept
of the 10,000 hour rule.
When you go so deep in something,
you can become an expert in it,
and when you love it that
much, you don't let it go.
And I think that's what winning is about.
And people, all sorts of
people, say all sorts of things.
Our perspective is to keep our heads down.
And we have a very clear mission,
we know why we're doing this,
we see every day what this means to people
in the context of the
ability to afford care,
or not go through what I equate to torture
in the context of traditional phlebotomy.
And that's what we focus on,
and that's all that we focus on,
because if we can keep doing
that, person by person,
we will realize this mission.
- What keeps Elizabeth up
at night, if you sleep?
(audience laughs)
And how do you go about tackling that?
- Well, I don't sleep very much.
- [Hostess] How many hours do
you get a night on average?
- I sleep about four hours, yeah.
I feel like the luckiest
person in the world every day
because of what I get
to do, and right now,
building this company is
about building people,
and really investing in
building the people from within
our company, so I spend as much of my time
as humanly possible focusing
on getting and building the right people,
because that's how we
realize this mission,
and how we realize this dream.
So, I don't think I could
be possibly kept up more
than I already am on that one.
I mean, the first time that
I went through the process
of raising money, I assumed
that I was going to have
to talk to at least 200
people before I found one
who was going to believe in me,
so I didn't really care if
people were turning me down,
because I knew I would
find someone who did.
- [Woman In Audience] How do
you make people believe in you?
- How do you make people believe in you?
You know, I think you have
to believe in yourself.
And I think you have to have
the conviction in yourself
to be able to make something happen,
because ultimately it's up to you,
and when you have that
level of conviction,
you'll find that people, or
the resources or the tools
that you need to make it happen.
It may take a lot longer than you think,
but it's about keeping that
conviction in yourself.
- So did you have a backup plan?
I mean, if this didn't work
out, what was your alternative?
Did you have one?
- No, and I think that the
minute that you have a backup
plan, you've admitted that
you're not going to succeed.
So we are not big on backup plans.
My journey was one of
jumping in feet-first,
and so I think if you know
why you're doing something,
and what it is that you're trying to get,
then it's a question of being
very, very open to failure.
And just trying again,
and again, and again,
until you get it.
So we codenamed our product,
what started as that patch,
the Edison because our
premise was we will fail,
over 1000 times, until we
get this thing to work.
But we'll get it on the 1001st time.
And I think that mindset has really guided
so much of what we've done,
because there's a
determination to make it work
no matter what, but you're
not worried about whether
many of those attempts fail.
You're embracing it, almost.
- How have you managed, I mean,
those are different skill sets,
founding and running a company.
How have you developed
each of those skill sets,
and how have you managed
to lead this company
from a small organization
to a big startup, still,
but startup today?
- Hopefully we'll always be a startup.
We've had the privilege of,
and I have had the privilege of
surrounding ourselves with
incredibly smart people,
and that combined with
jumping in and doing it,
and teaching myself, is the
way that I've approached
everything that I've done.
And there's nothing like
rolling your sleeves up
and failing a bunch of times
to figure out how to do it right.
I've always seen money
as a tool for being able
to make a difference, and for
us, we reinvest everything
that we make back into our company.
And we always will, because
it's about being able
to create better and better products
to realize this vision.
And so I never would have
built the company this way
if it was about making money.
It's about creating value,
and money becomes a byproduct
of being successful and creating value.
And then it's a tool to
reinvest and to be able
to continue doing that.
That's how we think about it.
I've been knocked down a lot,
and I became really clear that
this is what I wanted to do.
And I would start this
company over 10,000 times,
if I had to.
And there's been times where
we've invested in people,
where you build something like this,
and to me, the people in
our company have always
been like my family.
And you make mistakes,
you hire the wrong people,
and that can be incredibly painful,
because the damage that
they can do to the company
is really significant.
Now, we're under real attack
from the lab industry,
who is seeding all sorts
of bad stuff about us,
or false statements about us.
And we've had to keep
our heads down and focus
on what we are doing, and the belief that,
person by person, we will
demonstrate the integrity
of what we do.
But I think that clarity of purpose,
in terms of why we do it,
makes you capable of weathering it.
It's kind of like an ocean,
big waves come and they go,
but you're there for a reason.
I've always believed that
we're here on this earth
to try and make a difference in the world,
and so when I found what I felt
like what I was born to do,
which was to try and help
contribute to solving a problem
that I believe, at a human level,
there's not a lot that matters more.
- [Host] Access more
dental, save more lives.
- Yeah, and the saving more lives piece,
when you're talking about
someone that you love,
you'd do anything, right?
And to be able to solve that problem,
to me, that was the greatest
contribution I could make
with my life.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
one of you guys asked me to,
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want
me to profile next, leave
it in the comments below
and I will see what I can do.
I would also love to know which
of Elizabeth Holmes's top
10 rules hit you the hardest
or had the biggest impact.
Leave it in the comments and
we'll join the discussion.
And one last thing, my
goal with the channel
is to get it to one million subscribers,
that's the next goal, so
anything you can do to think of,
to share the video, tell
friends about it, tweet it,
add it to playlists, spread
the message a little bit.
I'd really, really appreciate it.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
continue to believe and I'll see you soon.